مما قاله الجيش الاسرائيلي انه قصف ست
منصات لاطلاق صواريخ وقذائف وصواريخ مضاد
للدروع للجهات الاسلامي في غزه
وهذه اعتقد لاول مره تستخدم المقاومه
صواريخ مضاده للدروع صحيح ان كنت
مخطئا ولكن اعتقد انها اول مره
ربما اول مره في هذه المواجهه حسب ما كشفت
وسائل الاعلام اسرائيليه القناه الثالثه
عشر تحديدا التي قالت بان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه اطلقت صاروخا مضاده للدروع
باتجاه ربما منطقه في غلاف غزه لكن هذا
الصاروخ وقع في منطقه مفتوحه لكن هذه ليست
المره الاولى المقاومه الفلسطينيه وجه
الضربات
لسيارات اسرائيليه كانت تسير على محاور
الطرق وايضا لسيارات ومعدات عسكريه بواسطه
الدروع وايضا حافلات نقل الجنود في
مواجهات
الاسرائيليه يؤكد تقول ان الصاروخ مضاد
للدروع اطلق امس من غزه للمره
الاولى منذ بدء العمليه العسكريه اذا هم
يسيرون الى هذه يعني هذه الجوله انجاز
التعبير وليس يعني بالمطلق
صحيح نعم نعم صحيح بالفعل وهو صاروخ واحد
لكن هذا ما يفسر عثمان الاجراءات الامنيه
المشدده التي ربما تشاهدها من خلف هنا في
حيث نتواجد في جنوب عسقلان المخاوف لدى
الجيش الاسرائيلي من استخدام صواريخ
الكورنيت الموجهه الصواريخ المضاده للدروع
هو ما يدفع الشرطه العسكريه الاسرائيليه
الى اغلاق طرق ومحاور طرق عده في منطقه
غلاف غزه معظم الطرق الرئيسيه المكشوفه
على القطاع ونحن نتحدث عن مناطق سهليه
وطبعا مناطق زراعيه مفتوحه ومكشوفه على
قطاع غزه وبامكان المقاومه الفلسطينيه ان
تسدد رمايتها بدقه ان ارادت صوب هذه
الشوارع وهذه المناطق لذلك الشرطه
العسكريه الاسرائيليه تغلق محاور طرق
رئيسيه لليوم الخامس على التوالي ونحن
قمنا بجوله سريعه هذا الصباح في بعض
البلدات القريبه هنا مثل سكين وكرميه وفي
هذه البلدات عثمان ايضا الجيش الاسرائيلي
يواصل
احضار المكعبات الاسمنتيه
لتامين وتحصين بعض المنازل المكشوفه وبعض
محاور الطرق المكشوفه على قطاع غزه كما
نشير الى ان الجيش الاسرائيلي منذ عمليه
الصيف الماضي في 2022 قام بشق طرق
التفافيه بين الحقول المختلفه هنا وبين
البلدات الاسرائيليه المختلفه هذه الشوارع
الالتفافيه عثمان تستخدم الان من قبل
الاسرائيليين في هذه البلدات للتنقل هم لا
يستطيعون التنقل عبر الطرق الرئيسيه انما
عبر طرق التفافيه قامت وزاره الدفاع
الاسرائيليه بفتحها في الصيف الماضي في
المعركه التي كانت في مطلع اب اغسطس عام
2022 مع الجهاد الاسلامي وبالتالي هذه
الشوارع
من تحرك الاسرائيليين او من بقي منهم في
هذه البلدات وهي ايضا تستخدم في عمليه
اجلاء الاسرائيليين المحاصرين في هذه
البلدات منذ ايام يشير هنا الى ان الاف
الاسرائيليين حقيقه عثمان غادروا بمحض
ارادتهم هذه البلدات حتى قبل ان تطلق
المقاومه الفلسطينيه طلقه واحده او قذيفه
واحده وهذه الاعداد تزايدت في الايام
الاخيره حتى الان لا يوجد حصر دقيق
للاعداد التي غادرت لكن هنالك تاكيدات في
وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه ومن قبل السلطات
المحليه في هذه البلدات المتاخمه للحدود
بان الاف الاسرائيليين بالفعل غادروا
منازلهم وطبعا الكثير من هذه البلدات تبدو
شبه خاليه في هذه الاثناء رغم وجود عسكري
ووجود من قبل حراسه البلدات هذه التي ايضا
طلب الجيش الاسرائيلي كما تعلم قبل ايام
بضروره استدعاء الاحتياط او التعبئه
العامه في صفوف الحراسه المسلحه في بلدات
غلا في غزه